but let’s all make
it harder to fish for
him, fame grew
at night, a large list of measures was carried
out,
starting from
two explosions of a dam in the
Chernogorka area in order to increase the
throughput, ending with
large engineering work there, and I can
say that the
liquidation of accidents is still underway, but the flow of water
the level has decreased significantly and the level
has already begun to subside from the flooding, the
sewage melting
has already passed the toilet bowl to call from the back of the house the hatch
where he can talk to you about what to
share with the water and the magazines of the participant of
yesterday evening will not go here, the
hours of the
chups are notified, you no longer need to go for a walk
I’m like a white dog in the morning walking myself,
but how about our boat, we got on the boat,
she’s sitting looking at it, my
dog ​​is so good, but well, in general, how
youtube is not warm to give, we landed and
then returned to pick up